we'll talk with you about how we define
these metrics what aspects of
sustainability should an organization
measure which I think is one of the
critical issues that we have to think
about and then the relationship of these
sustainability metrics to the
organization's general performance
measurement and management system the
challenge is going to be to integrate so
we have to develop these new ways of
looking at the world and of
organizational performance but then
after a while it's going to be very
important that they not be seen as
something separate oh that's just the
way we manage around here nothing
different than our routine and really
part of other types of metrics what are
the methodological issues raised by
measuring sustainability and I hinted at
that before the complexity of this issue
why it's important to do this and and
what what does this all lead us to
conclude with so how do we define
sustainability metrics so since this is
a course the sustainability management
I'm going to have to give you a
definition so they are an organization
or jurisdictions indicators of resource
utilization waste reduction and
pollution discharges into the
environment some being very focused here
there's a lot of other things people
might measure in fact in our case study
they talked about a bunch of other
things I'm going to try to focus on
these three things now according to one
set of authors that I'm quoting here it
includes material intensity energy
intensity water consumption toxic
emissions and pollutants they're
actually separating pollutants into
toxics and other pollutants because put
and toxic being those pollutants that
are most intense that can poison life
relatively quickly where some pollutants
can simply change things not always for
the better
some forms of pollutants are really
having too much of a good thing too much
nutrient too much nutrition in a lake
creates a set
of environmental impacts that you don't
want but that's different than taking
plutonium and dropping it off in the
middle of the lake one of them is very
toxic immediately and the other is
simply a pollutant there are no agreed
set of sustainability metrics
everyone has their ideas about what's
important and we should all expect that
this is going to evolve for quite a
while so let me focus on the aspects
that I think an organization should
measure and I should really say that
these are starting points I'm really
working and I do this here and I do this
a little bit in my writing I'm trying to
create some boundaries knowing the
people are going to take potshots at it
okay and that's okay that's really how
these things start that's how they
evolve so I don't want you to think oh
he said it was this therefore that's
true and in in your final exam I'm not
going to have a set of true or false
questions or multiple-choice questions
related to this in fact there won't be
any true or false questions or multiple
choice questions anywhere in this course
in part because we simply don't have
that level of information here so
material intensity is the first pounds
of material wasted per unit of output in
other words what is it that we're
throwing away that doesn't go into the
product okay that's one element of
material intensity but also is their
design for reuse does the product have
the potential to be returned for
remanufacturing or is it used up after
it's used is there some element of it
when you think about material intensity
one of the questions is is this is it
possible to recycle this are the
materials being used for this product
renewable or mined from one-time
geologic resources so it's not so part
of its can it be used again but part of
it is is this something that we don't
have to worry about whether it's
recycled because we can make more of it
because it's essentially solar and
organic in its in its orientation
so that's material intensity the second
area is energy intensity and this is
expressed as BTUs per unit it's a
measure of the net fuel energy consumed
to provide the heat and power
requirements of the production process
okay so that's energy intensity also
again renewable versus fossil fuels so
it's not just how much energy what's the
source of the energy and also the
efficiency of the use of the energy in
other words how much of the energy in
the production process could have been
recovered so we'll have a production
process that uses say a thousand dollars
worth of electricity but it turns out
600 of that was wasted there was waste
heat that went up the stack and we could
have used it we could have used that
energy for some other production process
if we had recovered it so these are all
factors the energy intensity that is
related to sustainability
third factors water consumption
expressed as gallons of fresh water
excluding rain water consumed per unit
of output how much water's is the stuff
use when we're making it okay other
factors though again with water the
reuse of the water what's the the
discharge when you release that water
into the environment can it be reused or
is it hopeless is it now water that
can't be used for drinking or for
growing plants also can we improve the
efficiency through improved transmission
reduced evaporation in the case of
plants more efficient plants in their
root structure so water consumption is
an issue that we have to measure toxic
emissions expressed as pounds of toxic
materials emitted by the process per
unit of output okay now these are all
quotations from the work that I've cited
here that I hope you've taken a look at
toxic chemicals are defined by a number
of pieces of US legislation we've gone
through a number of regulatory processes
to decide what's
toxic and what isn't but other factors
that need to be considered when you're
thinking about toxicity is the degree of
toxicity the treatment technology do we
have a way of dealing with it and also
even most importantly in my view is
pathway of exposure is this a toxic that
very easily gets into people's homes and
then into their biological systems is
there you know are these toxics that
once they're released have less of a
capacity to impair people's homes and
lives okay so those are all factors that
you have to think about and then there's
pollutant emissions which can be
expressed as pounds of pollutants
emitted by the process per unit of
output for every car there's X amount of
pollution for every you know for every
watch there's X amount of pollution so
you want to measure that how much how
many what kind of emissions are there
now that's for greenhouse gas emissions
but for other air pollutants also sulfur
dioxide other kinds of some of our more
traditional pollutants let's call it
then we want to think not just of the
pollution emissions but what's the
health impact and are the health impacts
things that we can do something about or
are they things that we can't do
anything about if the impact is asthma
is that something that's treatable
versus the impact being cancer which
whilst treatable perhaps is less
treatable so we actually have to look at
those things though this may sound a
little brutal but those are in fact
things you have to judge how bad is this
stuff is a question you have to ask and
has to be answered no other factors are
you know the issue of sustainability can
differ by geography okay you can have a
landfill in a desert and it's going to
have less of an environmental impact on
the surroundings because it's not going
to do much to ground water you put a
landfill you know you you know or you
you know if you try to hydro frack gas
by the watershed that's a little bit
different than if it's in a place that
doesn't have a lot of groundwater
not to say you should do in either place
but that is something a sustainability
metric would help you to measure and to
weigh along with other kinds of issues
and then you have to wait all this stuff
water energy toxic pollutants what's
more important as we develop the
measures for our organization in this
place all of which is going to vary by
what we do where we are and what's the
human settlement patterns are around us
okay now again I said human settlement
patterns there people would say well
that's unethical we should worry just as
much about the B's and the answers about
people well I know that there people
believe that and I I think that that is
an ethical choice that they make I don't
make that choice I'm more concerned
about people so those are the problems
in measurement I mean just think about
what I've just laid out you know all of
these different issues and all of these
complexities and how do you measure that
in an organization now
having laid out how complex is let me
just say that organizations do this all
the time you have to measure what an
organization does you have to measure
its performance this is an aspect of its
performance that's going to become more
and more important in organizational
management in part because of the
regulatory environment because
government's going to make people do it
in part because resources themselves are
becoming contaminated and scarce and we
have no choice because otherwise we will
degrade the resources of the providers
with wealth government it may lead us to
do that but corporations themselves may
see the importance of doing it and some
of them already have and then this is
cultural change which i think is taking
place which is to say that you know how
do we define criminal activity in a
society it's a cultural definition okay
you know in one society you know you pay
the trucker you know $1,000 a month to
make sure your truck doesn't get let's
say hijacked okay in some societies
that's the cost of doing business and
other societies that's corruption okay
those
things are socially defined well what
we're seeing is that increasingly and we
saw a little bit this in the Starbucks
case before that the social definition
of a well-run corporation is becoming a
sustainable corporation you and your
friends don't want to work for a company
that is doing evil
what's the Google motto don't don't be
evil don't do evil don't be evil okay
now they're serious about that they
actually think about is what we're doing
somehow adding to pain and misery in the
world okay that's become important to
people and that's going to be helpful as
we develop sustainability measures
what's the relationship of
sustainability metrics to organizational
performance and management systems now
as the organization learns these new
indicators that need to be developed as
we figure out what we want to focus on
as we come up with these metrics then
they have to be developed collected and
analyzed and reported at first
separately from routine indicators but
then they eventually have to be
integrated they have to be part of
routine management a key indicator of
success in fact it's going to be the
ultimate invisibility of distinct
sustainability metrics there needs to
become a time when we actually look at
sustainability metrics just like we look
at market share return on equity profit
and other more non-financial performance
indicators like you know how many things
that we produced what's been the cost of
breakage all sorts of indicators that
organizations put in and what's what are
what are our customers saying how many
complaints do we have what's the level
of satisfaction how much repeat business
you think about all the things an
organization measures itself against now
in the public sector these can be things
like test scores in a school system they
can be things like
in rates they can be indicators widely
ranging sets of indicators number of
homicides number of misdemeanors the
number of the amount of time it takes to
respond to a fire all of these kinds of
indicators are how organizations are
managed we managed and we define success
and manage organizations around these
indicators okay
so when we created the masters of the
sustainability management one of our
indicators of success is how many
applications did we get how many people
did we admit we want to make sure we
only admit about no more than half the
people that that apply and then how many
of those people come
well we want at least half of those
people to show up you know those are all
indicators of success now in the program
once it begins we don't want to see
people dropping out because they hate it
okay so our retention and attrition
rates are indicators of success
organizations run against metrics all
the time and so what this is saying is
we need to add sustainability indicators
to that mix it's very straightforward
what we're trying to do but it's very
hard so it leads me to the fourth issue
for today what are the methodological
issues raised by measuring
sustainability now part of the problem
is when you when you can when you
develop a measure you want the measure
to be reliable and valid reliable means
that every time you do the measure
you're measuring the same thing you
don't change it you don't change the
goalposts you don't change the scoring
system in the middle of of the
measurement you know you don't decide oh
this isn't going too well let's change
the criteria okay that's that's a
measure that's that's not reliable and
then they have to be valid you have to
measure what you actually think you're
measuring okay and when you so that's
the creation of the measure itself but
then once you decide what you want to
measure then you have to collect
information you have to collect
information in the same way you know
there was a story I think it was a
New York Times has a as a blog I think
its 5:28 or something like that or 538
the number of people in the Congress
does their pull it's their political
polling oriented website and they were
talking about I think was Rasmussen the
polling company and they discovered that
methodological II they had the worst
polls during this election they were off
more than anybody else and they looked
at how they were collecting their
information one of the things you do
when you do polling is you have to
randomize at the place of you know went
like when you make the call you have to
say you have to decide you want to talk
to the oldest female in the house and so
if the oldest male in the house is there
you say no no I need to talk to you
oldest female she's not here you hang up
you got to go to another person that's
how you randomize at the household
apparently they don't do it they do a
few other things in their methodology so
how you collect information has a lot to
do with the quality of the information
that you collect now when you're new
it's something when you're starting
something for the first time you don't
have a lot of experience collecting it
you make mistakes I mean you make
mistakes because you don't quite know
how to ask the question you don't quite
know how to calibrate your measurement
tools and so as you're doing it you have
to learn so after a while you figure it
out you get better at it you know you
get better at taking the measurement and
so eventually the your collection system
or works better so you need to
understand that the second method issue
here is the experience and skill in
collecting information itself and then
sometimes it's hard to know what to
measure you know we just went through
all those other measures right the whole
field of sustainability water energy
material so what's more important in our
area and then how do I wait them are
they all equal is some more is some more
important to my product or my
organization than others you know in a
service business does it really is there
is material intensity is important for
example is energy intensity probably not
but how much more important to take a
company like Starbucks a very
interesting point before
is this a service business that creates
ambience and the coffee's incidental or
is it a coffee company and the service
is incidental judging by the service I
beginning I think the service may be
incidental but no the question here is
you have to make that decision as you
create your measurement system and you
have to and what you decide to measure
then the and the definition of success
has a direct impact on the behavior of
the organization that's why this is so
important you know in the school system
when we start focusing on taking tests
teachers start teaching to the test they
don't care whether the kids are learning
they care whether they're performing
well on the test now if the two things
are the same great but if they're not
you've got a problem so measurement is
not neutral and it's certainly not
neutral within the organization okay so
you need to understand that as you think
about sustainability indicators and this
issue of cherry-picking indicators you
look to see what are we doing good at
let's emphasize that makes us look more
sustainable and particularly with the
emphasis on green washing you have to
watch for that weighting indicators in
an overall scale can it can introduce
bias and as we want to come up with an
overall sustainability measure like the
gross national product like market share
like the bottom-line okay what's it
going to be how do we put that number
together how do we weight it so that's
an issue that's still out there and I
think will vary by organization by
geography by product by service by what
the organization's distinctive
competences what is it trying to trying
to do in some cases qualitative factors
may be just as important as those things
that you can measure some of the
sustainability issues that are important
to you aren't subject to measurement yes
you know the fair trade issues you were
describing before which aren't part of
my measurement of sustainability but
might be part of yours how do you
measure that how do you measure
satisfaction how do you measure then if
you're comparing material intensity to
water intensity to energy intensity
which is more important but management
has to make these decisions and
one of the critical issues for a manager
is decide what's the definition of
success and how will you know if we got
there so in sustainability is the same
thing what's the definition of a
sustainability success for organization
and what are the indicators that I is
the manager I'm going to use to measure
against as we seek to perform it so
despite all of these problems and I
don't think I've been too shy about
introducing them to you
sustainability metrics are essential we
really have to figure out how to do this
we need to develop a way to
operationally measure success in this
area measurements force precision in
defining goals and then force precision
in the actions to achieve those goals
now sometimes that means you make
mistakes some of the first efforts at
measuring performance in organizations
were led organizations astray the
classic was actually in the military
during the war in Vietnam one of the
first quantitative performance
indicators used by Bob McNamara was
Secretary of Defense was body counts
they measured how many people were dying
they forgot something so they saw how
many Americans were dying how many
beaten to me soldiers were dying what
they didn't understand is that our
tolerance for loss was a quite a bit
lower than the Vietnamese because they
were defending their country and so if
they lost a million or two million
soldiers in the defense of their
homeland they were going to put up with
that if we lost 50,000 soldiers we
weren't going to put up with it
so the real measure of success probably
should have been territory held or
should have been something else besides
body counts but you know look like a
good measure seemed pretty important at
the time just happened to be wrong now
organizations always allocate scarce
resources all organizational resources
are always scarce and they allocate them
to focus on goal achievement there's
always a competition for the time and
energy of the people who work in an
organization
and so that's the other reason you want
sustainability indicators by creating
those indicators you then get into the
competition for money and people in an
organization okay if you don't have
those sustainability indicators then you
know people will be managing the
organization against other factors and
so it's absolutely essential to develop
these indicators or this activity will
not continue in an organization so
that's the the bottom line frankly of
why these measures have to be developed
the process of defining and improving
organizational routines which is what
we're talking about to make
sustainability happen in an organization
has to begin somewhere sometimes it
begins with a small step something that
you can get your arms around you can
define so let's say it's let's reduce
energy use okay let's just reduce our
electric bills okay that will make us a
more sustainable organization you see
that happening people are putting in
different kind of light bulbs and
they're putting in you know electronic
devices to control when the air
conditioning comes on and when it goes
off and motion detectors and all of
those kinds of things once the initial
sustainability's are developed they can
be applied they will be and then they
can be refined so the indicators
themselves are symbolic in its early
stages in convincing people in the
organization oh we're now being managed
against this we're going to be asked how
much water we use how much electricity
we use we might even be asked how much
garbage we're producing and how much of
a recycling maybe we'll weigh it you
start with the simple stuff the stuff
that we know are relatively easy to do
and then as time goes on you'll see the
measurements become more sophisticated a
benchmarking and learning new
organization routines from other
organizations is essential in new
management areas like sustainability
and so what you're gonna see is a lot of
people borrowing from each other people
going to other organizations and trying
to figure out well how do they do it at
Starbucks how they do it at Walmart
let's see let's try to imitate that
let's see if that'll work here
eventually you're going to start seeing
the indicators get more common and in
more general use you know we saw this
actually in the financial world with the
development of generally accepted
accounting practices though those
practices were not the first set of
accounting practices those are the ones
that developed over time as more and
more organizations started to use them
you're gonna see the same thing I
believe happened here so what does this
lead us to well first you know as I
talked about during our class on
performance management which is part of
the first few weeks I went through all
of the tools of management in order to
manage something you have to measure it
without measurement you can't tell if
what management's doing is making it
better or making it worse some
measurements essential very often though
when you start measuring something for
the first time you make mistakes and so
what's really important is that we
program an organizational learning that
we evaluate this that we keep trying to
relate it to goals the other thing that
happens in organizations is things get
ossified people get in they say this is
how we measure sedating ability around
here I don't care how they do it at
Walmart we're gonna do it this way
that's a bad thing you want this change
to take place early on we have a lot to
learn and need to be open to listening
observing and changing our
sustainability strategies and the way we
measure this success of sustainability
itself so and I've made this point a
number of times today that this is new
we don't really know what we're doing
yet we know that it needs to be done and
I've actually seen I mean in in doing
the book sustainability management and
in preparing for for this session and
for others there's been a fair amount of
development than the last ten years
enormous amount of progress have been
made a lot of ideas that that were there
at the very beginning of this literature
have already been set aside by I think
improvements and you're going to see a
lot more